politique toujours la campagne
législative s'accélère aussi pour les
candidats de la république en marche sur
la troisième circonscription des
yvelines
ancré à droite béatrice pire on espère
devenir député cette entrepreneuse de 51
ans qui se présente pour la première
fois à une élection multiplie les
réunions publiques pour se faire
connaître notamment auprès des habitants
elle y développe aussi ses axes de
campagne
on l'écouté au micro de nicolas kirilow
liszt j'ai quand même un côté un petit
peu donc intéressés par le développement
durable la transition écologique et
énergétique
puisqu'on est sur une belle
circonscription donc je pense qu'il faut
la préserver et continuer en ce sens là
et j'ai également un gros tu es
intéressé par tout ce qui est européen
parce que j'ai vécu à l'étranger et vu
de l'extérieur je pense qu'il est
important que la france soit au sein
d'un groupe européen fort et soudé
ils n'ont pas titre unique